hey guys
welcome to cmake episode 11 i'm going to
talk about
doing your libraries with visual studio
code and doing libraries with vc package
manager we've already seen how to do
libraries through sub moduling
we've seen how to manually add them let
me know if those aren't clear
but you should be able to do that when
you do the whole vc package
integrate install it tells you to do
this
what i have to do is set the cmake
prefix path
package cmake is supposed to set these
prefix packs i believe
but for some reason it doesn't and it
doesn't seem to do that ever so
maybe that's something that needs fixed
hey future editor matt here
um just want to say that this tool chain
thing actually works now so
like pull this over
so yeah i commented out the prefix right
and i put this tool chain back in i
completely deleted my build
and let it retry everything and it
actually works so i don't know why this
i have tried this tool chain thing like
so many times in the past
like within the last couple weeks and
this is the first time it's ever worked
so i don't know what changed
i did just update vc package manager
so maybe they finally fix this
awesome if so let me know down below if
you guys
get this tool chain to work for adding
libraries because it should be just
this simple you just have to have this
tool chain set and then you can find a
link
just in case this doesn't work you can
always do this set prefix path
to it manually all right
well going back to editing
uh you just do the fine package now this
is pretty standard here
when you do install the library it tells
you to do this
so for example um install
whatever fmt i'm using fmt because
someone
uh left a comment about they couldn't
get it to work
i didn't have any problems uh once i did
this prefix path
but the tool chain did absolutely
nothing so then you just do
it tells you what to do once you install
it so very good just make sure you get
the right
version of course and all that stuff so
of course you could do
like this is the 32-bit one here uh but
if we're building 64 you got to make
sure you have either have your triplet
vial set to it
or you do it this way already installed
so as we'll
see here this actually works and i've
got
just a little sample project here uh
just to make sure the library actually
works
extensions i'm using uh just the two
microsoft ones c
and c plus plus c make tools i'm just
going to go through basically how i set
up this quick
little workflow in visual studio
so those are the add-ons that are taken
over some things here doing this auto
cmake thing anytime you save
so very very straightforward project set
up here
just a root level cmakelist.txt
new version project called demo
executable with the project name
link uh the libraries
and you can link whatever libraries you
want of course
and i guess you have to set a prefix
path for each of them
until they get this whole issue resolved
with this toolchain file
and now of course you know you don't
necessarily have to have this set
here this is just setting a variable in
case you're
not real sure of that you can set these
as you run yours to your cma commands
too so you don't
necessarily have to do this right here
you could have it as your root level
cmake call
right here kind of like how it tells you
to
all right well in the main here just
included the format
and did a print and had a print before
so i guess we could should
probably go ahead and run it but i just
want to show you how i have the run set
up so rather than having to type the
whole cma command every time
i just made some little batch files and
i made one called rescan
that uh just basically rescans the cmake
stuff
and puts stuff in the build directory
and i made a build that runs ms build we
talked about ms build in last episode so
if you're completely not sure how to do
that
that's where it is if you're using a
different compiler that's fine you might
be using
bing gw or whatever you just gotta you
know you're doing it a different way
you might have to build the libraries
with me gw so you won't be able to use
vc package manager basically
all right so with ms build you build the
solution of course you can open the
solution
with visual studio and build it there
too but this is essentially the same
thing
so you could edit these batch files and
kind of get them set up for how you want
to do it
and i have an all that just goes through
all rescan build run
so if i just do uh it should go through
everything i should run it and it's
doing it
saying your bro code is this number code
we're using the the format
print so we know that it's linked and
all that and we know that we're getting
to the headers
that's how you do it let me know if you
have any questions let me know if you
want to see
any other ways of doing it
so hopefully you can see how to expand
from here
you could just basically keep going with
this and add in
whatever libraries you want just copy
pasta
and keep going and have whatever you
need ready
all right that's it for this episode
hope you guys enjoyed hope this uh
makes sense and you're able to get your
library set up with vc package manager
and visual studio code
all right see in the next one peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you